our planet is full of animals with
absolutely crazy anatomical adaptations
cheetahs can run up to 75 miles per hour
or 120 kilometers per hour frogs can
survive being frozen alive cows have
four stomachs and octopuses have nine
brains compared to all these other
animals humans might seem like we're
lacking we're not the best jumpers
climbers or sprinters and we definitely
can't hibernate or regrow our limbs if
they get cut off and yet humans occupy
our own very special part of the
evolutionary tree so much so that we
barely even consider ourselves animals
because when you take a step back humans
are incredible and you might even say we
are downright weird there is no other
animal quite like us we have so many
adaptations that are completely unique
to us there are the ones we use on a
daily basis and largely take for granted
our Nimble fingers big brains and the
ability to walk on two legs these assets
have allowed us to create mega cities
and occupy nearly every habitat across
the world as we've been exploring in our
nebula original series becoming human
but then there are the adaptations that
we don't see every day adaptations that
some of us have but never use or
adaptations that only select groups of
people have
from throwing to diving to high altitude
climbing when properly trained humans
are one of the most incredible athletes
of the animal kingdom
[Music]
if you're a fan of baseball you'll know
that one of the most valuable players on
any team is the pitcher the very best of
them can accurately throw balls at tiny
targets and reach speeds over 105 miles
or 169 kilometers per hour these throws
are so intense that since 1862 nearly
200 batters have died after being hit in
the head or the chest while this is a
tragic example of risk in sports we
normally think of as safe it's also
evidence of a trait that no other
species possess the ability to throw
projectiles and kill targets and it's
not only professional pitchers who have
such strong arms young boys between the
age of 8 and 14 who had moderate levels
of little league training could throw
two times faster than a chimpanzee even
though chimps are about four times as
strong as young men when controlling for
size you'd think that given the way
chimps and other Apes swing through the
trees they'd have much better throwing
arms than we do but several things
happened to our physiology during
Evolution that separates us from the
rest of the primates
first the length of our waist expanded
allowing our torso to rotate
independently from our hips next our
shoulders have developed a lower
position on the Torso and the glenoid
joint where the collarbone meets our
shoulder socket points out to the side
rather than upward like in chimps this
means we can turn our arms into levers
finally our humerus the bone in the
upper arm has a slight twist in it
allowing us to rotate the arm even
further back
putting all three of these elements
together creates an incredible throwing
machine twisting the arm back stores
energy in the tendons and ligaments
crossing the shoulder this energy
catapults the arm forward and actually
creates the fastest motion the human
body is capable of producing and all
three of these factors appeared in the
fossil record almost 2 million years ago
with our hominid ancestor Homo erectus
at the very same time we start to see
evidence of more intense hunting in the
fossil record in the form of butchered
bones and simple stone tools suggesting
throwing played a major role in shaping
how we got food and maybe even how our
brains grew so large unfortunately not
all Spears would have fossilized but
some certainly have wooden spear points
as old as 300 000 years have shown up in
archaeological digs in Africa Germany
and England while some ethnographers
argue that these Spears were too heavy
to go very far as projectiles a more
recent study conducted with trained
Javelin athletes found that these Spears
can be thrown farther than 50 meters and
at speeds ranging from 12 to 21 meters
per second at such high speeds and
distances it was more than possible for
ancient humans to take down large prey
from a relatively safe distance this
throwing ability may have also been used
for fighting between humans as well
which we can still see today whether
hunting or fighting was the key to
unlocking our killer arms it's clear
that this adaptation has had a huge
impact on how we live play and compete
but our early ancestors weren't only
expanding their abilities in hunting on
land they were also foraying into a
territory no other primate had ever been
one of our wildest adaptations is one
that was born simply out of a need to
not drown it's an adaptation that is not
unique to humans but one that humans
have learned to manipulate for
incredible athletic purposes in 2007 a
freediver reached a depth of 214 meters
holding his breath for longer than three
minutes while he plunged deep into the
ocean the record for stationary breath
holding is perhaps even more incredible
a full 24 and a half minutes without any
air
freedivers like this are making use of
the mammalian dive reflex a set of
physiological changes that take place in
the body in response to a mammal being
submerged in water and holding its
breath whether that's done voluntarily
or not
the dive reflex in humans begins when
you submerge yourself specifically your
face in cold water while holding your
breath the cold water triggers the
trigeminal nerve to send signals to the
brain stem to initiate the survival
response first the heart almost
immediately enters bradycardia a
dramatically slowed rhythm
then the capillaries in the fingers toes
hands and feet constrict and blood flow
is directed to the brain and heart as
the oxygen level in the lungs drops more
and more carotid bodies send out even
more signals to the brain stem to
further constrict blood flow in the
extremities in order to save it for
vital organs in a life or death
situation this response can keep enough
oxygen flowing to the organs that need
it most to keep you from dying but
there's even more happening with our
organs the spleen which helps filter
blood also controls the level of red
blood cells white blood cells and
platelets circulating our bodies when
humans go underwater the spleen responds
by Contracting to squeeze out a burst of
oxygen carrying red blood cells this is
another important survival mechanism
however when you compare the spleen
sizes of different populations in the
world you start to see that humans have
taken this don't die mechanism and
turned it into a badass ocean superpower
take the badge out people for example
who live around Indonesia the
Philippines and Malaysia they survive by
collecting shellfish off the sea floor
and are known for their extraordinary
ability to hold their breath they dive
repeatedly for about eight hours a day
to depths of over 70 meters for several
minutes at a time compared to nearby
non-diving populations the bajau have
spleens that are 50 percent larger and
this anatomical Quirk isn't just a
consequence of repeated diving the bajao
who don't do as much diving on a daily
basis still have a larger spleen meaning
it's an evolutionary response to this
group's diving lifestyle but researchers
think it's not just the bajau who have
leveraged the mammalian dive reflex to
get give themselves a leg up while
hunting perhaps our entire species has
been foraying into the Seas for a long
long time just look at our other primate
relatives for context gorillas and
chimps have the same diving reflex that
we do but they are nowhere near as
comfortable or proficient in the water
in 1960 marine biologist Aleister Hardy
proposed The Aquatic ape Theory
suggesting that early humans foraged for
aquatic foods and spent hours at a time
in the water he pointed to things like
our furlessness and the layer of body
fat under our skin that other primates
don't have but the theory became
something of a catch-all an umbrella
argument used to explain many elements
of the human body it was largely
dismissed by the archaeological and
anthropological communities that said
there is evidence in the fossil record
of our close relationship with aquatic
environments a homo erectus site in
Northern Kenya holds the butchered
remains of turtles crocodiles and Fish
dating back nearly 2 million years and a
number of Neanderthal skulls have been
found to have extoses bony growths in
the ear canal that forms with repeated
exposure to cold and wet conditions in
modern humans they're often found in
Surfers divers and swimmers and even if
free diving didn't shape our Evolution
from the beginning there's certainly no
denying that people today have learned
to push the limits with the Aquatic
adaptations we do have for those of us
who can't imagine diving three meters
down or holding your breath for more
than a minute it's worth mentioning that
all of these skills can be improved with
some training leading researchers to
suggest that maybe we are all better
suited to the Aquatic world than it
might initially seem
while we might all have some ability to
throw a spear or hold our breath and
swim there are some human adaptations
reserved for only a select few
adaptations found high in the mountains
at sea level in cities like Boston or
Miami the atmosphere is filled with a
comfortable 21 oxygen but as the
altitude increases the effective oxygen
level begins to steadily drop the
percent of oxygen in the air Remains the
Same but there are far fewer molecules
of it available to our needy lungs above
1500 meters in cities like Boulder
effective oxygen dips to 17.3 percent
above 2 000 meters it dips below 16
percent and physical activity becomes
more difficult and you might feel way
more out of breath than usual above 2500
meters effective oxygen drops to 15
percent and without acclimatizing about
50 percent of people will get altitude
sickness which can develop quickly and
be life-threatening headaches nausea and
shortness of breath are common but in
the worst cases fluid can build up in
the lungs or the brain can swell both of
which can be fatal above 3000 meter
effective oxygen drops to 14.3 percent
and chronic altitude sickness affects
five to ten percent of people who spend
months or years there this is a result
of long-term hypoxia it leads to having
too many red blood cells which can cause
the blood to thicken and increase the
risk of blood clots heart attacks and
strokes the problem can even result in
heart failure in the long term and over
four thousand meters effective oxygen
drops below 13 percent and for most
people without acclimating acute hypoxia
is certain this can rapidly progress to
the more severe and potentially fatal
high altitude cerebral edema and high
altitude pulmonary edema but these risks
almost completely disappear for a
certain subset of people a subset of
people who have historically lived in
three high altitude locations around the
world the Tibetan plateau in Asia the
Andean atiplano in South America and the
samian plateau in Ethiopia these
locations range between 2500 to over 4
000 meters in each of these places the
human body has adapted remarkably well
to harsh conditions but not always in
the same way in the Andes and some parts
of high altitude Ethiopia Highlanders
have more oxygen-carrying hemoglobin in
their blood than those who live closer
to sea level having more hemoglobin to
carry oxygen through the blood system
than people at sea level counterbalances
the effects of hypoxia but in Tibet and
other parts of high altitude Ethiopia
people have far less hemoglobin than the
andeons at levels more similar to people
who live at sea level they instead have
genetic changes that have allowed them
to use smaller amounts of oxygen more
efficiently for one they naturally take
more breaths per minute than people who
live at sea level and then on top of
that their lungs generate larger amounts
of nitric oxide from the air that they
breathe this nitric oxide Works to
increase the diameter of their blood
vessels allowing them to deliver oxygen
throughout their bodies more effectively
than sea level people do and of the
Tibetans there is one group that uses
this natural ability to its extremes the
sherpa climbing Community the sherpa are
one of the Tibetan ethnic groups native
to the most mountainous regions of Nepal
Tibet and the Himalayas and of this
group those who have dedicated their
lives to mountaineering are regarded as
some of the most elite mountain climbers
to have ever lived Sherpa tenzig Norge
was the first person to Summit Mount
Everest alongside Edmund Hillary in 1953
and since then Sherpa records on Mount
Everest have not stopped Sherpas hold
the records for the most descents to The
Summit 26. in fact the top 10 summiters
are all Sherpas the longest stay on the
summit which was 21 hours which he did
without bottled oxygen for reference
most people stay for 20 minutes and the
fastest Ascent to the summit which he
did in 10 hours and 56 minutes this last
record is particularly ridiculous to
think about the total distance from the
South Base Camp to the summit is 20
kilometers with an altitude change of 3
500 meters it takes most people 6 to 10
weeks to do this climb having to make
many shorter up and back acclimating
ascends part way up before being able to
make the final push to the summit and
this guy did it all in 11 hours I don't
think I I could even walk on flat ground
in a nice environment for 11 hours
straight and for most foreigners who
have managed to reach the top many many
Sherpas were involved in laying ropes
ladders and carrying equipment to make
it happen a physical burden far beyond
just climbing the mountain
the sherpa record Setters are trained
seasoned professionals with years of
practice and experience boosted by
unique high altitude physiology some
people even try to mimic this enhanced
ability for exercise by training at high
altitude but the benefits they get from
this strategy are always short-lived
only those populations that have a long
history of living in high altitude
places have genetic changes that allow
their bodies to thrive in places where
most of us struggle how the human body
will continue to change in the future is
an open question because Evolution isn't
done with us yet just as we can't fathom
what abilities future humans might have
so too would it have been impossible for
our early ancestors to imagine how far
we've come and how very strange the
journey has been would our ape-like
ancestors have imagined their
descendants totally abandoning
quadrupedal movement for an upright
stance would they have imagined those
liberated hands to start crafting
complex tools or for communities to
create languages and systems so complex
that they would one day travel amongst
the Stars The evolutionary journey of
humans has been a total departure from
anything else that has happened on this
planet our story utterly unique even
among the primates what makes us so
special how did the spinning wheel of
evolution land on us to become the ones
to dominate the planet this is a topic
that's fascinated me for years but I
shied away from exploring it on this
channel since it's a bit more
philosophical and anthropological than
what we normally do here but now thanks
to nebula we've been able to explore the
subject of human evolution in depth with
our new nebula original series becoming
human which you can watch the first two
episodes of right now by signing up to
curiositystream.com real science to get
in on the nebula curiosity stream bundle
deal thanks to nebula we've been able to
take the precious time to craft a whole
new 3D Museum that features in every
episode showing you the actual fossils
and skeletons of the early human
ancestors that were cleaning with this
stunning imagery the series takes you
through the steps of how it is that we
became human and by signing up to nebula
through the Curiosity stream bundle deal
you get a great price for just 14.79 you
get access to both curiosity stream and
nebula for the entire year curiosity
stream is a streaming platform in itself
with tons of great Nature Documentaries
like my favorite series evolve which
dives into the fascinating world of
biomimicry and explores whether the
unique adaptations of the animal world
can help us to find futuristic solutions
to some of our biggest problems and once
you sign up to curiositystream you'll
get an email inviting you to nebula this
is also the single best way to support
this channel every sign up makes our
sponsors happy which makes us happy
because it means we can keep bringing
you more and better content and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now you can watch our latest
video about the surprising reason some
sharks live inside underwater volcanoes
or you can watch real engineering's
latest video about a new way to achieve
nuclear fusion